since the financial crisis a major
aspect of British life has changed in a
profound way fewer people can afford to
buy their own homes and those that do
buy them later combined with the decline
in social housing more people than ever
are in the private rental sector
including low-income families with
children and the most vulnerable this
sector is poorly regulated offers little
security and have seen rents rise
exponentially in London they're up by
almost 40 percent in a decade
in Bristol there's been a more than 40
percent increase since 2011 while in
Edinburgh they will rise by 16 percent
in the next five years the Capitals
Mayor Sadiq Khan has proposed a new
system of rent controls already common
in much of Europe and North America that
would put a check on these
out-of-control prices the case in favour
is overwhelming and our MPs one in five
of whom are landlords need to put aside
their own interests and support change
in the interest of the millions who need
it we are becoming a nation of renter's
and it's about time we adjusted right
you and Lord oh no but that's probably
about the only sensible thing that's
ever come at a concert agree with anyway
my family all live in London and none of
them can afford to live where they want
to live okay
nobody gets a step onto the ladder on a
thing anymore and it's extremely
difficult Olivia and you look at areas
that you know around where I am even you
know Shoreditch and London fields and
what they've been gentrified and it's
snobbery and it's all sort of put the
pride they've almost forced the normal
man out you know I mean they want to
keep the part nice job my lad but they
forced the normal manner so there are
there are things I'd like to see happen
you know so you know it's in controlling
rent and that sort of stuff I'd like to
see it capped but I'd also like to see
people you know it measures in place
like perhaps paying the landlord
director have you check and not giving
people the chance to get themselves into
arrears and what sort of stuff as well
because that's that's another part it's
putting once you get into arrears you're
in a proper onion he's now making up
because you lost it in the first place
so with people who are struggling on low
incomes their money shouldn't be
Bank which does now because there's easy
administration that money should be
going straight to the landlord direct
and that sort of stuff so there are
stuff we could do to slightly help but
as to the problem of rent being sky-high
is it hideous problem and it is and just
probably everyone else and it is about
more than people's bank balances is
about community isn't it and I just want
to read you a quote from Hanna Slater
she's the policy manager at generation
rent and she says unaffordable rent
increases force people into stressful
moves away from neighborhoods where they
have roots thereby eroding communities
renters need stability in our homes that
can only come from certainty over what
rent we pay but we need to be able to
afford a home in the first place so I
think that goes to the heart of what
you're saying our communities are
changing our cities are becoming only
places for the rich and well high
earning professionals and we need cities
that are making communities who've been
there who have roots as well and it's
just this is an interesting washing so
one of my cousins does place he's up on
that right okay he said to me years ago
it used to be Casey the kitchen was the
focal point of the house now because
everybody can afford to eat out in these
affluent areas the kitchens the smallest
room in the house and they're doing them
and that's just a small sign about
things are going well much as you were
the cause for right-wing increase in
right-wing tension in the previous part
of the show you have just displayed your
total economic illiteracy all that will
happen and there was research that
proves that instead they will just use
them almost as we're you can use as
containers or air B&B or ever it might
be or kids coming back from college or
university for the summer if you look at
some examples on the face of it although
I never liked the idea of government
controlled anything that's in the
private market Connor I believe in
turning down government control and
letting people sort themselves out on
the face of it it's one of those things
that oh yes that can work in practice it
probably doesn't I said what learn what
action and if I had loads of rooms in
London
I just won't let him I'm not gonna make
the government control I'll just put
storage in it or put kids in it after
what I'm not familiar with Stockholm I
am familiar with New York and I have to
underscore everything he said okay it is
an issue to finish it is an issue of
supply and demand we haven't got enough
supply this won't this won't turn the
supply right I am familiar with
Stockholm do you know why because it's
the the one example that right wing
commentators always used to say this
doesn't work I'm not saying that this
doesn't that these systems often don't
have loopholes that
landlords and developers get around and
that is a problem but if you look at a
lot of German cities you look at Munich
you look at Berlin you look on a lot of
other cities in North America this
system is working it's not perfect but
when I listen to people like that who
says this is going to be bad for the
poor in immigrants what are they doing
about the reality that those people I've
done reporting here about the fact that
one-fifth of private rental
accommodation properties in this country
are not fit for human habitation and
those are the exact groups that live
there nobody's worried about them
nobody's proposing anything but all I
would say is I totally understand where
you're coming from and and and and in
theory I agree with the sentiment but in
practice it just does not work as
somebody who has owned properties and I
stupidly sold them you won't be saying
here today let me tell you I think when
it comes to the rent market we
understand the issues but actually Sadiq
Khan who Trevor and I we know very well
I think what he hasn't done is he hasn't
made good on his promise to build more
homes and actually that should have been
his number one priority he could have
fought together multi-stakeholders and
actually created his own fund to build
houses under his watch he could have he
they didn't need to go to develop I was
serious about that he could have done it
himself
I'm Hollywood Yunnan listen this is a
free hit for them he should be better
than that you know I'm sort of with you
that statistic about the rise in private
rent particularly in London yeah
tells us that rents increase by 38%
between 2005 and 2006 teen that the
question I would have for you f-words
why this solution which clearly hasn't
quite cut it you talked about the way
communities have changed the biggest
change in most communities particularly
London communities look at the high
street commercial property empty why
wouldn't our first priority be to make
the planning process work in such
way that we can turn those high street
properties into residential properties
very quickly because I think that would
be the fastest way of making more
properties available and keeping rents
down rather than getting into this
rather better use of Greater operation I
when I proposed this I can say it
because I think it's quite a radical
measures we've never done in England
before but I don't think it's not only
solution we did we had a rent-controlled
in this 50s and 60s but it was a
different model though it was a
different model of protection but if we
I think there's also we also need house
but I think we need to build more social
housing we need to build more housing
because one of the reasons it's because
of the shortage I don't in any way deny
that but I think this is one piece of
the puzzle that we should look at and I
agree with you about reforming planning
laws but I don't think that always
turning high streets into more
accommodation is always the answer
because you get these kind of sleeper
communities where there's no commercial
activity where there are no communal
spaces where people just live so they
can commute somewhere else to work and
you get very dead areas and we're
already seeing that in a lot of towns
where the high streets moving out of
London anyway we need to start
developing other parts of the country so
actually maybe what will happen in the
future is this won't be the focus of
everything and that's actually what the
Americans have been very good at
creating hubs where you have different
sectors in different parts of the
country so it's spread out at Chester or
Bristol when that place becomes a new
hub the rents rise exponentially there
too and that's why I think we need rent
control I can just see